figure de la variété à la télévision
dans les années 70 marie carpentier
s'est éteinte hier à paris deux ans
après son époux gilbert l'ensemble des
sites populaires que numéro 1 encore la
grande farandole de location d'un couple
mythique de blanche et d'une émission de
divertissement
il y est écrit une belle page chic et
distingué spirituelle à billets qui
faisait rêver notre télévision c'est
elle on pouvait l'imaginer pour eux
puisque au cours de leur suggérer et il
attend cette vente
et c'est ce que nous avons toujours fait
votre vie et
jusqu'à 25 bien continuer à être des
relations avec qui c'est qui va retomber
souchon géniale idée c'était une famille
et les gens qui sont sortis alors adieu